الدوري الانجليزي كاربخال يسخر من طرده
بطريقته الخاصه وريال مدريد يحسم صفقه هذه
الاخبار ننقولها لكم من العربيه رياضه
اهلا بكم
اصبح مدافع مانشستر يونايتد السابق احدث
المنظمين لقاعه مشاهير الدوري الانجليزي
ويعد هو اللاعب السابع عشر الذي يدخل هذه
القائمه المميزه ولعب ريو 540 مباريات في
البريميرليج مثلا خلالها خمسه فرق كما فاز
بلقب الدوري ست مرات مع نادي مانشستر
يونايتد
وصل ريال مدريد نتاجه السلبيه في مسابقه
الدوري الاسباني وخسر امام ريال سوسيداد
خلال هذه المباراه الحكم طردا داني
كارباخال لاعب ريال مدريد الذي قام بعدها
بنشر الصوره على انستجرام مباشره من غرفه
الملابس برمز تعبيري ضاحك تاكما على قرار
حكم المباراه قبل ان يقوم بحفز بحذف ستوري
الذي تناقت تناقلته صفحات الرياضيه على
نطاق واسع
خبر اخر يخص ريال مدريد ومشجعيه حيث وبحسب
صحفيتي بيلد وماركا
فننغام الى ريال مدريد ستحسم خلال الساعات
القليله المقبله حيث تتبقى فقط بعض
التفاصيل الماليه بين الطرفين ويعدوا بناء
لاعب المنتخب الانجليزي هدفا للعديد من
الفرق الكبرى في اوروبا وصفقه انتقاله من
دورتموند لن تقل عن 120 مليون يورو